SPEAKER 1: Today, one
in every 68 children
has a diagnosis of autism.
The spectrum is becoming
wider and wider.
And because of that, there
are lots of misunderstandings
and misconceptions.
Some employers are thinking
about making accommodations
when we talk about autism.
Some people assume
if a kid has autism,
he must be having
a very high IQ.
Some parents are feeling
like the world is ending
when their kids get diagnosed.
None of these is accurate.
Today, we are very
fortunate to have
the director from UW,
University of Washington Autism
Center, Annette Estes.
She is a research professor
in the Department of Speech
and Hearing Services, and an
adjunct research professor
in the department of
psychology at the University
of Washington.
She is also a
licensed psychologist
in the state of Washington.
Her research is carried
out at the UW Autism
Center and the Center on Human
Development and Disability.
Now, let's welcome Annette.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNETTE ESTES:
Thank you so much.
OK.
Hi.
Thank you for coming today.
So we're going to
spend lunch together,
and I'm going to be
talking about autism.
We have time for questions.
I kind of like taking
questions periodically
throughout the talk,
so I will do my best
to remember to do that.
So, an autism spectrum
disorder is a general term
that is used to describe a group
of complex disorders of brain
development.
When we talk about autism,
we're usually-- at this point,
we're thinking about two
domains of functioning.
One of them is
social communication.
The other is restricted
and repetitive behaviors
or interests.
And these impact
children and adults
in a number of different ways.
So first of all, in the
communication domain,
we think a lot about language.
Language development
can be delayed.
Some children never
end up functionally
being able to communicate.
But with early
intervention, at this point
most people can develop
the ability to talk.
A lot of people on
the autism spectrum
actually have language
abilities in the typical range,
and it's more about the
non-verbal communication
where you see the impairment.
So for example, gesture
use or eye contact
or emotional expressions
are sometimes
lacking in individuals
with autism.
And sometimes, the
understanding of those kinds
of non-verbal
behaviors are lacking.
With early intervention,
many people
achieve quite good levels of
communication and language
development.
But what you often see is
a difficulty integrating
the verbal and the non-verbal.
So even in individuals who have
achieved what we would consider
typical levels of being able to
communicate, sometimes things
are a little bit off.
So maybe you'll have eye contact
without verbal interaction,
or vice versa.
You might see a person talking
without making eye contact
or using typical gestures.
So this can impact people
in a number of ways.
The reason that we talk
about social communication
is it's really hard to
disentangle communication
and social ability.
So, social-emotional
reciprocity is another aspect
of communication.
So that social approach,
sharing interests, feelings,
initiating, responding
to social interactions,
all of these things can
either be diminished
in individuals with autism,
or sometimes even lacking
entirely.
But again, since we're
talking about a spectrum,
it's not always the
case that there's not
an interest in
social interaction,
but there's often difficulties
in developing or maintaining
or understanding relationships.
And this can come about
for a number of reasons.
So sometimes, it's
adjusting behavior
to suit the variety of
different social contexts
you find yourself in, whether
it's a child on the playground
versus at a family reunion
versus in a classroom.
Sometimes, it's due
to the fact that kids
aren't as interested in peers.
Sometimes it's
interested, but not
knowing how to kind of
initiate or connect with kids.
And early on,
imaginative play is
so important to
child development,
but also just in terms
of what kids do together.
And this can be a specific
area of difficulty
for kids on the spectrum.
So, restrictive and
repetitive behaviors
are the other circle that we
talked about at the beginning
of today.
And this can kind
of manifest itself
in a couple different domains.
So, one of them is in
stereotyped or repetitive motor
movements.
This is something that people
notice kind of pretty easily.
So that could be
rocking back and forth
or flapping your hands
if you're really excited,
that kind of thing.
But it can also be a little
in a different domain.
It can also have to do with
repetitive use of objects,
or even repetitive speech, so
saying the same kinds of things
over and over again.
And you can see in the
picture here a little boy
who winds up his toys
in a specific way
from smaller to larger.
And that's an example
of a repetitive
type of use of objects.
The other dimension of this
is insistence on sameness,
or inflexible
adherence to routines.
How this might look is a parent
bringing their child to school
a different way than
they normally drive
and having that result in a
lot of distress for the child.
That's not something
that, typically,
developing kids
worry about too much,
but a lot of kids on
the autism spectrum
get thrown off by
those type of changes.
Another dimension is a highly
restricted or fixated interest
on something.
So you know, again,
this doesn't have
to be an unusual something.
It can be Magic the Gathering
or other things that kids--
that a lot of kids that
age really love to do.
But kids on the
autism spectrum seem
to focus on that exclusively,
or with a lot more intensity
or focus than other
kids their age.
But it can also be an
unusual kind of interest.
So I've had kids that
absolutely love refrigerators.
That's not a very typical
thing, but you know,
we have had experts on
refrigerators and vacuum
cleaners and all
sorts of things that
are unusual in their focus.
The other thing that
just got added officially
to the diagnostic criteria
is hyper or hyposensitivity
to sensory input.
So this can be textures
or sounds, or even
visual kind of interests.
And the way that
this can manifest
is anything from having only
certain types of clothes
that a child wants to wear--
I'm seeing some nodding
and smiling in here--
you know, having
to cut tags out or only wear
a certain kind of blue jeans,
that kind of thing.
But it can also be just
being able to hear things--
it doesn't have to be
startling to loud noises,
it could actually be
hyper-awareness of sort
of not very loud noises.
Like right now, there's a little
bit of a high-pitched sound
going on.
I don't find it disturbing,
but a person with autism
might have a really
hard time concentrating
due to this noise.
AUDIENCE: It's a squeaking
fan and the AC [INAUDIBLE].
ANNETTE ESTES: Squeaking
fan and the AC.
There you go.
So that can be a problem.
So the other way-- I hope
I'm kind of describing
how autism is a spectrum.
But some of the
ways that I think
it's easiest to
understand this spectrum
is to understand that some
people, like [INAUDIBLE]
already told us, have highly
adapted intellectual abilities.
So, it's true that some
people on the autism spectrum
are far above average in terms
of intellectual functioning,
but a lot of people--
but it really
spans the whole spectrum, and
there are a significant number
of individuals with autism that
are intellectually disabled,
that have a very
hard time functioning
due to intellectual impairment.
So that's, again,
one of the myths
that-- you can understand
why, because there
are people with autism
that are very, very bright,
but not everyone has that gift.
Also, some people have
a language impairment,
and some people don't.
So that's another
kind of way that this
manifests as a spectrum.
One of the most
important things is that,
to be an autism
spectrum disorder,
the difficulties have to
present early on in development.
So this is before age three.
And they also have to cause
clinically significant
impairment.
So this is an important
point that I'll
sort of pause on for a
minute, because if you think
about autism, so difficulties
with social communication,
restricted and repetitive
interests, all of us
can see some of ourselves
in those type of symptoms,
I guess, or those kind
of characteristics.
So you know, not all of
us are highly social.
Not all of us always feel like
we're understanding what's
going on in social situations.
Some of us might be more
particular about how
things are lined up, or maybe
don't like change very much.
But to have an autism
spectrum disorder,
it really has to significantly
impair your life.
It has to be a problem.
Whether it's in
school, if you're
a school-aged
person, development
if you're a little guy,
it has to cause problems.
And so that's something
to keep in mind,
because I think all of us can
relate to this on some level.
So, OK.
So, all of this that
we've talked about
is reflected in the
Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders.
This is the--
essentially, it's a book
that psychiatrists
and psychologists
use to diagnose people
with all different kinds
of psychiatric disorders.
You can see up here that
it started with the DSM-I,
and has gone through
five iterations now.
And just to clarify
for some of you who've
known about these kinds
of disorders for a while,
in the DSM-IV, the
previous iteration,
we had Autistic Disorder,
Asperger's, Childhood
Disintegrative Disorder, Rett's,
and Pervasive Developmental
Disorder.
And all of those
are now subsumed
under this umbrella of the
autism spectrum disorders.
So if anyone had a
diagnosis before that
had a different
name, now it's just
called something different.
But it's still part of
the autism spectrum.
So, any questions about what we
just talked about, or comments?
That was a very
quick Autism 101.
Yeah.
Yes.
What is-- so the question is,
if you have an 18-month-old,
for example, how do-- what
do these kinds of things
look like?
I am so glad you asked that,
because my focus of my research
and a lot of what
we do is focused
on the youngest ages, when
autism first starts to emerge.
So hopefully by about
the middle of the talk,
you'll know more about the
answer to your question
than you ever thought you would.
That would-- so we'll
see how that goes.
So, what's important about
an ASD diagnostic evaluation?
So, why do people want
to get a label like this?
How does it help?
So, the first thing is it
can be a key to accessing
appropriate services.
Whether it's medical,
psychological, behavioral,
educational, all of those
things can fall into place
much more easily if people
know that a person has autism.
Also, parents get information
about the next steps.
So a good diagnostic
evaluation will
include recommendations
for intervention
that are individualized
to that person.
It will also help clarify that
person's individual behavioral
and developmental difficulties,
but also their strengths.
I think a lot of times when we
do the testing that's involved,
you can really see where
a child's abilities are.
And that kind of
gives you the in you
need to start--
sort of jumpstart
some learning processes.
And then, in the
best of all worlds,
parents and caregivers can
get support and education
about autism.
So, a lot of people, after
they get this diagnosis,
find themselves warmly embraced
by the autism community.
And that would be-- it's
a really important thing
for a lot of people to have that
support along the way, and also
information from other
parents, because that
can be really, really helpful.
So here, I wanted--
what I wanted
to do next is show you a video.
This video is of a girl
who was evaluated--
I think we evaluated her
probably 15 years ago,
so I don't think she would be
recognizable at this point.
But also, they
did-- her family did
sign a release of
information, so you
know it was OK to show this
for educational purposes.
And I wanted to
show you this video
because this is the typical
age at which a child gets
their first official
diagnosis with autism.
And this is a girl who
I also had a chance
to know throughout her childhood
all the way up till when
she was a teenager.
And I will just tell you that
her last evaluation with me,
she knew more words than I did.
I had to go look up some
of the words she was using.
So she was a kid who
was highly capable.
And here she is at age four.
And what I'd like you to do
is notice the differences
in her approach to the
situation than you might
expect other four-year-olds.
So if you don't know
about four-year-olds,
I'll clue you in.
Not surprisingly, I'm
going to ask you to look
at her social interaction.
So, she's in a room
with two adults.
One of them is her mom.
The other one is an
examiner who knows--
has just had a really fun time
with her for about an hour.
So a lot of-- so these are
people who she's familiar with,
and who are fun.
She also-- I also want you to
see how often she initiates
or responds to
social interaction,
what she does when
she communicates.
What is she talking about.
Is she directing it at people.
Is it social.
And also look at what
she's doing with the toys,
and see if you can see some of
the restricted and repetitive
kinds of interests
that she shows.
OK.
So I imagine that you
noticed several things
about the social and
communication and repetitive
behavior domain when
you were watching that.
Does anyone want to make
comments or observations
about what you saw?
So this little girl was not--
she was a pleasant person.
She didn't cause a lot of
problems for the grown-ups
in her life, which
can sometimes,
for kids on the autism
spectrum that have not
a lot of challenging
behaviors, that can actually
delay how long it takes them to
get identified, because you can
imagine that she's a really
nice girl to be around.
However, part of that was
because she wasn't initiating
social interaction
like you would expect
most four-year-olds would
not give you probably
30 seconds in the room
without them coming up to you
and showing you things,
bringing you things, asking you
to be on the floor with them.
She did have communication.
You heard her say numbers.
You heard her-- I guess
that's probably all
you heard in that little clip.
But she didn't direct anything
to other people in the room.
And she also, as you
noticed, lined up blocks.
She actually was putting
them all with the same thing
on the top, the little letters.
And then she had a ritual that
included some repetitive motor
mannerisms and a repetitive
kind of verbal sounds
that she would make.
So those are the kinds
of things that you
might see that, again-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is what makes
it difficult, because--
ANNETTE ESTES: Right.
So the question,
to sum it up, is
how do you tell
whether something's
typical or not typical,
because basically kids are
quirky people, right?
I mean, that's kind of
characteristic of childhood.
So what makes
somebody have autism.
And a lot of that has to
do with having a real sense
of typical development.
So you know, knowing
how often you
would expect a child
with typical development
to be initiating
social interaction.
Lining things up specifically
isn't such a bad thing.
It's do you do that
without any social--
without any communication,
and do you kind of maybe
get distressed if that-- if
you're not able to do that.
Do you have a variety
of things you're doing.
So these are some
of the questions
that I think, if people
have these questions
about their own child or
another grandchild, a neighbor,
anything like that-- I mean,
neighbors get a little hard,
but if you have
worries, you know,
feel free to consult--
there's a really
good website, First Signs, that
has some nice video examples.
But also, I think coming in
for a diagnostic evaluation
or a screening is
a really good idea.
There are some things
online, too, about that.
So if anybody has
questions, let me know.
So as [INAUDIBLE]
said, one in 68 kids
have been-- the most recent
estimates from the CDC
is one in 68 kids have
autism in the United States.
One in 42 boys, and
one in 189 girls.
So not considered an un-- it's
considered a common problem
at this point.
When I first started
giving these talks,
we would say that autism
was a rare disorder.
We don't say that anymore.
One of the interesting facts
about this more recent CDC
study was that the
prevalence rates
ranged from a low of 175
in Alabama to a high of one
in 45 in New Jersey.
And people have
wondered about this.
I think it's interesting.
I can only speculate.
I am not an epidemiologist.
But one thing I
happen to know is
that there are very,
very few services
in Alabama for any
developmental disabilities.
And New Jersey, on the
other hand, charges $1--
or gets $1 of every
speeding ticket
in the state of New Jersey to
go towards autism research.
And that's just
the research piece.
So they have an amazing kind
of comprehensive identification
and intervention
program in New Jersey.
So I think that it's not
that people are moving there,
it's that there's
sort of more awareness
and that there's more
professional kind of-- more
professionals that
understand autism.
And also, people-- there's
more reason to get a diagnosis.
So back to the what do
you-- why would you do this?
Well, you would do it if
you had good intervention,
because otherwise
it's probably not
that helpful to come forward.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's always
struck me that there's
such a gender divide with this.
Is there any explanation or
musings about why this is?
ANNETTE ESTES:
There are musings.
So the question is about
why more boys than girls.
It's about three to
one boys to girls.
This is common among a lot
of the childhood disorders.
So, ADHD has a similar
kind of prevalence.
And there's a lot of people
that are interested in this.
Actually, I'm going back to--
I have a couple studies that
are funded by the NIH Autism
Center of Excellence Studies.
And one of the
[INAUDIBLE] not mine,
but another one of the
[INAUDIBLE] that was funded
is specifically to better
understand that question.
So there's a lot of speculation,
but one of the things
is that girls seem to have
some sort of protective factors
early on.
So whether it's something
about girls' brains
are more resilient than
boys' brains, it seems like,
and we're trying to understand
more about what that is.
Of course, that kind
of switches in puberty,
where girls start to have
higher rates of anxiety
and depression.
So there's a lot to
understand and unpack there.
But probably-- my
best bet would be
to look into the biology and the
underlying kind of differences
in the brain.
So the question is
why do kids get autism
and how are they more at risk.
I will get to that.
That is good.
OK.
But quickly, a
couple more facts,
and then we'll get there.
So co-occurring
medical conditions,
these can include
GI difficulties.
So a lot of kids having
problems with eating
and distress due
to gut problems.
Sleep problems and sleep
disorders are really common.
It's a very difficult
thing for the whole family,
I think, oftentimes
for people with autism.
And then seizure disorder.
So about-- well,
it's interesting,
because there are some
kids that get seizures
early on, like under age
two, that end up with autism.
But most people with autism
that go on to have seizures
are teenagers when they
are first recognized.
And so this is something that
is important to look out for,
if kids start to have sort
of staring spells or changes
in their functioning.
That's one thing that
people need to look out for.
AUDIENCE: And what do you
mean by gastrointestinal?
Do you mean like things like
diarrhea or constipation?
ANNETTE ESTES: It can be
diarrhea, constipation.
There's-- some people think
that there's a higher rate
of Celiac, so difficulty
with gluten, in autism.
It's unclear whether
that's truly higher,
or if it's just that it's
harder to recognize it.
But certainly, there
seems to be more reflux.
Just all sorts of things
surrounding the gut.
Interestingly, the
gut and the brain
are highly connected
early in development.
Those cells are actually
the same cells early
on in fetal development.
And so there may be
something around that.
Then over time, and during
school age and into adulthood,
there can be a co-occurring
psychiatric and developmental
disorders in addition
to the autism.
And this is something that,
again, this new DSM was good,
because it helped us
be able to-- there
was, like, rule-outs that you
couldn't have autism and ADHD.
Well, that was not
really reflecting,
I think, the natural
history of the disorder,
which is that, yes, you can
have attention problems.
Anxiety becomes quite pronounced
in a lot of individuals
with autism as they
get older, like
teenage and early adulthood.
Learning disorders.
So even when somebody--
a learning disorder
is when you have
typical development,
or typical intellectual
ability, but you
have a specifically hard
time with a certain area,
like, say, reading
or math or spelling.
Something like that.
So that can happen at a higher
rate in people with autism.
Actually, we had a study,
including a lot of people
here in Seattle, that
showed 90% of our kids that
had an IQ of 70 or above had
either an extremely unusually
high ability in a
certain academic area,
more than you'd expect by the
IQ, or a really low ability,
much lower than you would
expect based on their IQ.
So this poses a lot of
challenges in school.
Intellectual disability is much
higher in people with autism,
as well as speech and
language problems.
OK.
So, causes.
Here's your slide.
We have-- this is a
really-- I'm going
to give you the
complicated answer first,
because it is complicated.
So you know, there's-- we'll
just have to deal with that
in autism, I think.
The causes are
probably an interaction
between-- over the course
of early development,
between some pretty
complex factors.
So each one of these
factors in and of themselves
is not simple.
But the first thing we
know is that there's
a genetic basis to autism.
We know this from twin
studies and family studies,
and now we know it because
of the increasingly good
technology that allows us to
be able to really pinpoint
very small changes
in the genome that
are related to autism risk.
We know that their
brain structure
can be different in
people with autism.
And I'll tell you a
little more about that.
We know this through
neural imaging studies.
We also know that
brain function,
through functional
neural imaging studies,
can be different.
And we also think that there's
some prenatal factors that
might go into increasing autism.
And how I think about
the prenatal factors
are it's sort of anything that's
bad for the brain probably
increases autism risk.
So for example, there
were early studies
with thalidomide, which was
a substance that parents--
or moms took when they
were pregnant to help them
with nausea.
And it turned out that it
was very bad for babies,
and it also increased
autism rates.
So babies that were
exposed to thalidomide
had higher rates of autism.
We know this through some
studies of viral infections,
and people are now looking
at all sorts of factors,
everything from air
pollution to other kind
of toxins in the environment.
These things-- so again,
anything bad for the brain
probably increases autism
risk, in conjunction
with the genetic factors that
I'll talk about in a minute.
So once you kind of have a baby
with these sort of early signs,
these early behavioral
deficits probably
cause a cascade of
developmental problems.
So if you're not
paying attention
to the speech of your--
of people around you,
then you're not going to be
learning to talk as well,
right?
And if you're not
sort of more orienting
to social interaction,
you're going
to miss out on a lot of
learning opportunities,
because that's how babies learn.
So these things kind of set up
a developmental cascade that
can end up resulting in autism.
So that's the answer.
It's very complicated.
One of the things I
really want to focus on,
though, is the autism genetics.
So at this point, we understand
that the primary cause
of autism is genetic.
However, when you take
one step further into what
does that mean, you're back into
a very complicated situation,
because some of the genetic
factors are inherited,
some are not inherited.
They're de novo mutations.
The de novo mutations tend to
be-- they can be very rare.
They don't occur in
very many people.
But when they do, they're
very powerful risk factors.
So these have begun to be
identified more and more
in the population.
So it doesn't affect that
many people, but when it does,
it's a really important
set of information
that you can get from that.
Most people with autism,
it's more complicated.
There's-- we used to think
that there was going to be five
to 10 genes that we
would recognize--
we would be able to find
that accounted for autism.
Now we're up to, like,
300, people are thinking.
So these are mostly
common genetic variations
that, together,
have small effects,
and they kind of interact
with one another.
And in different
people, and along
with other later occurring
factors, might lead to autism.
So any individual may not have
an identifiable genetic cause
for their autism, but probably
about 10% to 20% of people with
autism, they're-- at this point,
there could be a genetic kind
of answer to why
they got autism.
So at this point, we would
love to see everybody
that has an autism diagnosis
get a genetic testing done, just
to see if they are
among those people
with those small rare
mutations that might also
have some medical follow-up
associated with them.
But again, that's not going
to pay off for everybody.
But it's certainly worth
it for those people who do
have those kind of factors.
Oh, I see a hand.
Yes.
Most of the rarer and the
more powerful mutations
are not inherited.
They're de novo.
They just arise in the course
of early, early genetic-- well,
when the fetus is being
formed, basically.
And so for the
most part, there's
some-- there's
some families where
there are inherited factors.
Most of the time, though,
those are those common variants
that I was talking
about that, if you
have five or six of them,
you don't have autism.
Or if you have-- I don't know
the number, because we're still
sort of doing that
research, but let's say
that if, in one individual,
there were 10 genes that
caused their autism,
you might have
to have nine out of those
10 to increase your risk.
So these are oftentimes
kind of subtle factors
that we're talking about with
the inherited forms of autism.
Now, that's not
the case for some.
So I guess-- just as
you say one thing,
there's exceptions like
fragile X syndrome,
for example, which,
in fragile X,
you can see pre-mutation
carriers that
don't have fragile X, and
then, in one generation,
it will show up.
And this can be, you know-- so
in that case, it is inherited.
But usually the
parents don't have
symptoms that are recognizable.
So it's-- yes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is there any correlation
between siblings'
chances [INAUDIBLE]?
ANNETTE ESTES: There are.
So in the 1990s, Tony Bailey
and some others in the UK
did some of the
first twin studies.
So they studied monozygotic
twins, or identical twins,
and the dizygotic twins,
or fraternal twins.
So the monozygotic twins
share approximately about 100%
of their genes, dizygotic
twins about 50%.
And then they've studied sort
of like cousins and further out
relatives.
And what they found
was exactly what
you would expect for a
highly genetic disorder.
So the monozygotic twins had
about a 90% concurrence rate.
And when you got
to dizygotic twins,
it was about-- I'm guess--
I forget the-- I'm trying
to remember the study.
It was a long time ago.
But it went way down.
And then the further out you
went, the less concordance
you had.
So the less chance of
having both siblings.
You notice it wasn't
100%, which is
why we are also interested
in environmental factors.
And we also understand now
that genetics is not so simple,
either.
With something
called methylation,
you can change gene expression
due to environmental input.
Anyway, it gets-- it really
is a fascinating area.
But it's not my
area, and I realize--
I spent about 10
years of my life
doing what they would
call phenotyping, so
doing the diagnostic
assessments for families that
were participating in
our genetic studies, some
of the first studies where
there were two or more kids
with autism in the families.
And I started to
realize that I was never
going to be a
molecular geneticist,
and so I would probably do
better as a psychologist,
thinking more about the brain.
And became really fascinated
by some of the early studies
that our group and
others published,
because what it appeared
was that the genes
that we were finding all
express themselves in the brain.
This is not surprising now, but
it was pretty neat at the time.
And so not only are these
genes expressed in the brain,
but they're also typically
expressed early in development.
And they're a lot
of times related
to neuronal development,
or the cells-- neurons
are the cells in the brain.
So it's how those
cells proliferate,
how they connect to one
another, and that kind of thing
that seems to be related to the
genes that we're identifying.
So, this was in 2002.
Our group began doing a
large-scale study that
included multiple views on
people with autism, including
doing brain imaging studies.
And these were, at the
time, the earliest--
we were told, actually, some
of the reviews that came back
for this grant was, well,
you can't identify autism
as early as three
to four years old.
So how are you going
to find these kids?
But we did.
And what we found was that the
kids with autism had about 10%
enlargement in their
brain as opposed
to typically developing kids.
And then the kids in the
developmentally delayed group
without autism actually
had smaller brain size.
So this led us-- and other
groups replicated this,
it became one of the most
replicated findings in autism
in terms of a biomarker,
one of the first.
So, related to this-- oh, yes?
So the question is whether
developmental delay and autism
are the same thing.
They're actually not.
You can have autism and not be
delayed in your development,
although I guess only
on certain measures,
because of course by definition
you are socially delayed if you
have autism.
But there's a number
of ways that you
can have developmental
delays that are not autism.
I mean, I don't know how-- it's
kind of a complicated thing,
but that's why our
psychologists stay in business.
AUDIENCE: From that graph,
it looks like [INAUDIBLE]
will never co-exist.
[INAUDIBLE]--
ANNETTE ESTES: You can
define it so that they don't.
In this case, it
was developmental--
AUDIENCE: Because you
either have a smaller
brain or a bigger brain.
ANNETTE ESTES: Well,
it's-- you know, this was--
our DD group was 15 kids.
So you know, I wouldn't
take too much from that.
The developmental delay group
had multiple different reasons
for being delayed.
And it so happened in
our group that they
had smaller brain size overall.
You can definitely have autism
and developmental delay.
But in the way we defined it,
it was developmental delay
without autism.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANNETTE ESTES: Yeah.
So, OK.
So back to-- so we're finally
getting to your question
about when you can
diagnose autism.
So just a quick
poll-- I don't know
how to do this without making
everybody cheat and look
around, but that's OK.
What do you think the earliest
age is to diagnose autism?
So how many-- raise your
hand if you think four.
I already sort of
said we could do that,
so I guess I gave that away.
Three?
OK, I said that, too.
Two?
Under one?
OK.
So we have two and under one.
More people in the two.
Well, I am going to tell
you what I think about this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
ANNETTE ESTES: I'm trying to
make it easier for you guys.
So yes, there's no
between one and two.
I'll have to change that.
So, let me tell you about
some of the earliest
signs of autism.
So between 12-- between one and
two, what you start to see--
and this is based
on research that's
both retrospective
research, where
parents talk to us about
what their children were
like when they were growing up.
It's also based
on a new approach
that I'll tell you more
about of looking at infants
who have older siblings
with autism who
are known to be at higher
risk for developing autism.
So there's also
prospective studies
that look at development
in these younger ages.
And what we find is-- you'll
see the word less here
in the social domain.
So less orienting, less
looking at-- to people
when there's social
kind of things going on.
Less initiating, less
sustaining of engagement,
less coordinating,
fewer gestures.
Some kids have delayed
language milestones,
but there's not a lot of
language going on at this age,
right?
So the bar is fairly
low here for everybody.
And repetitive
behavior was thought
to not occur at this age,
but our group recently
did a study that
looked prospectively
at these infants
with older sibs,
and found that there
really were more
subtle forms of repetitive
behavior going on at this age.
Not so much the motor
movements or winding things up,
because again, these
kids are very young,
but would tend to focus more
on objects, sort of palm them
in their hands back and
forth, that kind of thing,
for a lot longer than
you would expect.
So this was the beginning
of repetitive behavior.
And just to let-- for those
of you that say how can you
tell the difference?
I'm going to show you a little
video of typically developing
babies so that you can
kind of get a sense of just
how social little guys can be.
OK.
Whoops.
That goes on for a while.
OK.
And so you can see that, even
before kids learn to talk,
they're doing all
sorts of communication.
They're sharing enjoyment.
They're imitating each other.
There's a back and forth
to their interactions.
And so if you're kind of
grounded in typical development
and you interact with
a little one who's
not showing some of those
early emerging skills,
you can actually detect
differences in some people
earlier even than a year.
And right now, we're
involved with a four-site--
it's actually larger than
four-site-- four clinical site
study, University of
Washington, Washington
University, Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia,
and University of
North Carolina.
And what we're doing is
studying these infants
with older siblings with autism.
And we're doing brain
imaging, as well as
behavioral assessment.
The reason we're focusing
on these infant sibs
is that recurrence
rate is about 20%.
So if you have a baby and
you have an older sibling
with autism, there's
about a 20% chance
that that baby's going
to have autism, too.
In addition to that,
there's a 30% chance,
if you don't have autism, that
you might have other learning
problems, whether it's
speech and language
or specific learning
disabilities.
So the idea here is
to assess and monitor
infants who are at
risk for autism,
and understand what's going on
before their symptoms emerge.
So we're getting-- yeah.
Sorry.
Quick question.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for that number.
What is that 20%?
Does that mean for autistic
child and there's a 20% chance
that his sibling will
also have autism?
ANNETTE ESTES: The baby
will have autism, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
That's really high rate.
ANNETTE ESTES: It is
a really high rate.
AUDIENCE: Comparing to one in--
ANNETTE ESTES: One in 68.
AUDIENCE: 40-- 60, yeah.
ANNETTE ESTES: Yeah.
Exactly.
So, that's right.
So this is a group
that, I would say,
needs assessment and
monitoring, but also we
can learn a lot from.
So we're getting babies in at
three to six months of age,
and then assessing
them at 12 and 24,
and then again at 36
months with brain imaging
and behavioral assessment.
The brain imaging is
done, by the way, asleep,
so no sedation.
So late-night studies,
very dedicated families.
And what we found in
our initial study was,
at six months of age,
you could already
tell-- see some differences.
These are assessments that
were done by evaluators looking
at gross motor at six months.
Let's see here.
So we have six months,
12 months, and 24 months.
And the red line are kids that
went on to develop autism.
The brownish line
is kids that went on
to develop a milder
form of autism.
So they had-- they were
still on the autism spectrum,
but their symptoms were milder.
These are high-- and
these are both high risk.
Here's the high risk infants
that did not develop autism.
And then the blue line
is the low risk infants
who had older siblings that
were typically developing.
And already at six months,
you can see some differences
in the groups.
And those groups' differences
increase over time.
This is parent report of
how the kids were doing
at home and in the community.
And you see the exact
same type of pattern.
With children that go on
to develop autism at six
months were already lower
in their adaptive behavior
than high risk infants
that had mild symptoms.
And then-- or milder symptoms.
High risk that went on to not
have autism, and then low risk
that had no autism.
So development in infants
at high risk for autism
in the first year
of life, this is
something that differs starting
as early as six months.
These differences
are mild and subtle.
They're not the kinds of things
that you would necessarily
walk into a clinic and
be able to pick out.
But these symptoms unfold
and develop over time,
and there's a convergence
between both parents
and clinicians.
So here's the real
answer to your question.
So it's a bell-shaped curve
when kids actually have
the full syndrome of autism.
There are very rare cases--
rarely before eight months,
but between 8 and 12
months, you actually do
have a very few rare number
of babies that will show
the full syndrome of autism.
These symptoms kind of
coalesce and emerge,
and by 24 months of
age, most children
who are going to go
on to have autism
will be able to be identified
if they're seen by a specialist.
And then some kids,
though, don't really
show their full
signs until later.
I would say only very
rarely do symptoms
occur after age three
for the-- you know,
really the first time.
And yet, you might notice that
the median age of diagnosis
in the United States
is five years of age.
So this is our challenge, that
we can reliably diagnose autism
by 24 months of age.
Sometimes, before 12.
And yet, the average age is
four to six years when people
are actually getting diagnosed.
So there's this gap.
And the gap is even
more painful when
you look at that second
piece of information
there, that usually between
the first time a parent brings
in a child for an
evaluation, there's
another year before
they actually
get the answer from
the professionals
that they are seeking.
So it's something
that parents have
called a diagnostic odyssey,
going from person to person,
doctor to doctor to try to
understand what's going on
with their child's development.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So on our journey--
I could add some color
to this-- on our
journey, we started
to realize that our son was
autistic when he was two.
We did a couple of visits to see
if we could get confirmation,
and when we called for the
evaluation, it was May.
And the next available
appointment for an evaluation
was February, 10 months later.
ANNETTE ESTES: Right.
AUDIENCE: And so once
we got to the point
that we realized that we needed
an evaluation, the soonest we
could get one was
10 months later.
So that's part of what
adds to the [INAUDIBLE]
ANNETTE ESTES: Right.
It's really a huge challenge.
And one of the things that
we're going to try to do
is use some of the
early brain findings
that our group and others, I
guess, but it's really mostly
our infant brain imaging
study have come up with.
And this is differences that are
present before the symptoms are
really clear.
And you can see these are
DTI images, diffusion tensor
imaging.
And they show-- the areas
that are kind of in brighter,
hotter colors are
areas where there
was higher-- something
called fractional anisotropy
in the children that went
on to develop autism,
as compared to the kids
that didn't develop autism.
So the connections
between the parts
of the brain in infants
that go on to develop autism
are already different
at this early age.
And there's a couple
other findings
that we're working on
publishing right now.
And what we hope to be able to
do is, for parents who-- you
know, that eventually
what we'd be able to do
is get something a little
cheaper than an MRI
to be able to
identify differences.
But once we know kind of
what those differences are,
then we can maybe
work on figuring out
who's at the highest
risk so that we can maybe
develop preventive
interventions,
or at least know who to really
do some close assessment
and monitoring with
so that there's not
a 10-month wait for people
who are at the highest risk.
So this is maybe obvious,
but what we aim to do
is start intervention
as soon as possible
after autism symptoms
emerge, because this
leads to the best outcomes.
We would like to provide
intervention and support
across the lifespan.
Usually, people with autism need
supports at all different steps
along the way.
Even the people who respond
the best to early intervention
still can face challenges at
all the different developmental
points along the way.
And one thing that we
know from our work at UW
is that early intervention
does improve outcomes.
We did the very first
randomized clinical trial
of early intervention,
and recently just did
a follow-up of that.
But that first finding was
that we could improve IQ
actually average of 17 points.
Some of the kids
gained 30 points of IQ
during the early intervention.
Improved communication,
reduced diagnostic severity.
This evidence was
really important.
It might seem obvious to
people who've gone through it
that their kids get
better, but having evidence
means that insurance
companies will pay.
So it was work that I think has
yielded really important gains
that way.
We also just published the
first-ever follow-up study
that showed that these
gains were maintained two
years after early intervention.
This paper was named as one
of the most influential papers
last year by NIH.
And again, it seems
like a sort of no duh
when you look back on it, but
nobody had done this before.
So one of the
interesting things is
it looked like there was--
I know there's people here
that like data, so
one of the things
I will show you is this is--
you can't see this very well,
but here's the early-- this
is our intervention group.
The red is the control group.
And here, we have
18 months of age.
A year later, about
four years of age.
And then this is
six years of age.
And what happened is
the kids didn't really
differ in their autism severity
during the early intervention.
But two years later, they did.
So what we think-- and but what
they did differ on right away
was their IQ levels.
So what seemed to
have happened was
kids maybe gained
the ability to learn
from a typical environment.
They were able to be in typical
classrooms, to-- you know,
we don't really know
what happened exactly,
but they had a lot
less intervention
during those two years after
our study than the kids
in the control group.
And their autism symptom
severity went down a lot
during that time.
AUDIENCE: Question.
How early is early intervention?
ANNETTE ESTES: Well,
these kids entered
the study between 18
and 30 months of age.
And, yeah.
So, one of the
things I want to say
is being in the
Pacific Northwest is
a really-- something I
don't take for granted.
We have-- we could never
do all this research
without a supportive community
and supportive families that
are amazing that they would
do things like stay up
half the night with their
babies to get a brain imaging
study done, or bear with us
for-- I guess they give two
years of a longitudinal study.
There was a lot
of questionnaires
and a lot of assessments.
And it's pretty neat
to be in this region.
One of the other
things that was--
that's been a true
pleasure for me
is becoming the director
of the Autism Center.
So not only do I
do research now,
but I get to have a clinic
where we can develop clinical
services, hopefully that
use what we've been learning
in research for all these
years and start to make it--
these state-of-the-art
evidence-based clinical
services available that we can
do research that's relevant,
because we're kind of in the
trenches with people and facing
some of the same problems
that the families are facing.
And we also know
that we are not alone
going to be able to
meet the needs that
exist in our community, so we do
a lot of professional training
to increase community
knowledge and skills,
because that's how I
kind of sleep at night.
You know, I know we can't help
everybody one person at a time.
And, let's see.
We have just a few minutes.
I won't talk too much about
our clinical services,
just to say that we do have
an infant clinic now based
on what we learned
from our families
in the infant brain
imaging study.
People really valued
having that assessment
and monitoring along the way.
We have ABA services,
social skills groups.
We want to start
this process of being
able to be on the playground
and using a program called
Remaking Recess for
kids to be socially
included during recess.
We have a summer camp.
So we're working on it.
And I'm going to skip
through all these specifics.
We also do training.
I want to invite you all
to-- invite your teachers,
and if you are teachers, come.
We have a free two-day
workshop for educators,
two different times.
One is on transition
to adulthood in autism,
and another one is for
elementary school-aged kids.
And we have flyers up there.
So get your teachers to come.
It's going to be good.
And it's free,
because we're being
supported by a community group
called the St. Johns Masonic
Lodge.
So they raise money for us
to be able to provide this
to teachers.
We had 700 teachers last year.
And this year, we're hoping
for 1,400 over two days.
Or two different times.
So, community support
is where it's at for us.
We just wanted to put in a
plug if you have ideas, energy,
entrepreneurial thoughts,
financial support, mentorship,
or networking, we're
all about that.
So come and talk
with me afterwards.
Or Jim Boyle, who's here from
the University of Washington.
He can also tell you more
about how to partner.
And then, stay
connected with us.
This is our website,
our newsletter,
and our first-ever gala
dinner is in September.
So, that's it.
I think we are just on time.
So, feel free to stay afterwards
if you want to talk more,
if you have any other questions.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]